hey this is hilarious we've not done
anything like this for a while because
we haven't talked about Christian
televangelist Pat Robertson for a long
time he's still at it he's hosting his
700 club program he's 89 years old he
still has that same co-host he still
takes these audience questions where you
can't tell if they are parodies or
serious questions from people who don't
realize that it doesn't make any sense
to go to Pat Robertson for advice I was
sent this clip yesterday where someone
said David you've got to see this Pat
Robertson got a question from some guy
who claims that his wife wants to bring
in their Christian pastor as her extra
lover she wants to swing or she wants an
open relationship or something with her
pastor and the husband went to Pat
Robertson asking what should I do
so when I heard about this before even
watching the clip I was wondering is Pat
Robertson going to take it seriously or
will he identify it as a fake trolling
question I don't know if it's a joke or
if it's for real but what I knew
immediately was if Pat Robertson takes
it seriously he is going to attribute
his wife's behavior the e-myth the the
viewers wife's behavior to demons
because with Pat Robertson everything is
demonic over the last 10 years on this
program Pat Robertson has called the
following things demonic secondhand
sweaters that you get at Goodwill they
could have demons attached to them from
the previous owner Ouija boards yoga
anything Harry Potter feng shui the I
guess it's Japanese design interior
design technique karate' the martial art
horoscopes the Twilight series paintings
of Buddha TV shows about ghosts
Halloween
obviously psychics young girls who
levitate their friends at sleepovers
definitely demonic and sometimes even
children that you adopt from other
countries can come with demons attached
according to Pat Robertson so let's get
right into the clip how does he handle
it exactly as predicted this is Michael
Pat who says dear Pat I've been married
to my wife for eight years and we are
very active in our local church last
week she shocked me when she said she
wants our pastor to be her quote extra
lover
this does not make any sense since I
give her all the love and compassion
that I can give our pastor does not know
her plan should I talk to him first
before she tells him oh you'd better
talk to somebody that is the realest
mycological good there's a sex problem
she is been captured probably by some
demonic spirit but what's she saying
she's married to you has a successful
marriage with you you give her whatever
she wants but she wants a quote extra
lover where does she get that concept
yep there it is it's demonic possession
for sure I love how he diagnoses demonic
possession in the same casual way that a
plumber tells you the flapper on your
toilet needs to be replaced it's like
the exact same demeanor oh yeah that's
that's demonic possession that's what
that is then this is also funny later in
the clip the co-host seems visibly
shocked that someone who's active in a
Christian Church could also be wanting
to have sex with her pastor outside of
marriage take a look
why does she get that concept that is
absolutely wrong and she's active in her
local church so she being active in
church really doesn't mean anything much
it just means you're active it doesn't
mean necessarily you know you're giving
over to the Lord you need to talk to
that pastor and you need to alert him to
what's going on and then you need to get
that wife to some kind of counseling and
deliverance because she she's being
captured by something that sounds
extremely evil all right Pat Robertson
actually correct here I mean listen he's
completely out of his mind but he's
right just being active in a Christian
Church doesn't make you anything and he
could not be more right about that one
little thing a broken clock right I
guess once every few decades in this
case it sounds to me like the wife needs
a good old-fashioned exorcism to solve
this problem
so what do you think is this fake or not
I mean on the one hand who would even
write to Pat Robertson with a problem
like this like who who thinks that Pat
Robertson could solve any problem but at
the same time he's still going he's
still on air so there must be some
people that see Pat Robertson as a
mayor of good sound advice which may be
the scariest thing of all I want to hear
from you leave a reply leave a comment
if you're watching on youtube or send me
a tweet at de Pakman after following me
of course do you think that this was a
serious question or is this just a
satirical troll